yet to shake off concerns about
potential for foreign spying
that have spooked government
worldwide. So joining us now is
the chairman. The senate
intelligence committee, mark
Warner. He recently introduced a
bipartisan bill expanding
president Biden's legal
authority to ban tiktok
nationwide. So hello, we're
wondering what he will be
listening to today. Thank you so
much for joining us. So are you
zeroing in on choose answers on
what tiktok does with this user
data. What are you going to zero
in on today? What a couple of
things. First of all, it's even
worse than your date, and I
loved it. That earlier
presentation on average tiktok
users are using tiktok about 90
minutes a day. I bet you wish
everyone in the CNN for yours
spent 90 minutes a day on on CNN
. And respectfully what this
what the tiktok CEO says, of
course by dance would never turn
this over to the communist
party. He doesn't have any say
in that. China changed its law
in 2017 that requires every
company when requested. The
turnover data to the government
. So the notion and one of the
geniuses of tiktok is it learns
from you. Every time you're on
the site, it starts to get to
know you what you like better
than even what you know. Do you
want all that information
ultimately residing under the
guise of the communist party of
China number one number two.
This is a powerful propaganda
machine. If it's used that way.
You pointed out that Canada
leaving tiktok version that
Chinese kids say doesn't have
the kind of stuff that that our
kids see. It emphasizes. Science
engineering. Be a good student.
Be a patriot, um this is an
incredible misinformation.
Disinformation machine. I'm not
saying they're doing it right
now, but that potential
president XI and China wants to
somehow invade wants to invade
Taiwan. And suddenly, folks not
only in America, but around the
world are starting to see videos
that reinforces that kind of
message. That is a propaganda
tool. That makes every every
other possibility pale, so I
think there needs to be a rules
based approach that says, when
we've got technology from
countries like China and Russia
, there needs to be the tools
that say if they pose a national
security threat we will give the
secretary commerce tools to take
care of that we've gotten out.
10 Democrats 10 Republicans
backing of the administration.
This is not the first time we've
had this kind of issue a few
years back. It was a Chinese
telecom company wall way before
that it was the Russian software
company kaspersky. We need a
rules based approach that takes
on foreign technology from
adversarial nations senator
given that is there anything to
CEO can say today to convince
you that tiktok isn't a national
security threat. I I've
respectfully met with the CEO.
I've met with the tiktok team.
I've heard them out. Uh, I don't
think they are owned by bite
dance a Chinese company at the
end of the day. I don't think
they're masters of their own
fate. Chinese law. Trump's
anything that the corporate
management wants to do. And I
would point out one other thing
that I think will make hopefully
make the point. President XI and
the Chinese leadership have said
they would rather get rid of
tiktok in America than give up
the source code. The magic
formula that resides in beijing.
If through divestiture. Part of
the requirement was that source
code had to be located in
America. There's 22 points of
fact here, senator and I think a
lot of people share your
concerns. But our Brian Fong did
a great fact. Check just on what
we actually know versus the
fears that are laid out. There
is no public evidence that the
Chinese government has actually
spied on people through tiktok.
There was that surveillance of
journalists which was very
troubling. They were fired,
terrible that happened, but also
to date, no public evidence of
beijing has harvested tiktok's
commercial data. For
intelligence or other purposes.
I just wonder if you have any
fear. About choking something
off that helps a lot of create
or something. Just finish the
question, choking something off
that that the means a lot to a
lot of creators and small
businesses and as a source of
revenue for them, and that way
before these worst fears are
realized. I've read through your
restrict act. I know what it
does, but just respond to that
concern. Check let me let me
doing a reverse order. First of
all, there's a lot of creative
stuff on tiktok there. We've
seen the influencers. They make
their living off of this, and
frankly, there are other
American sites, YouTube and
others my understanding at least
reimbursed at a higher level. I
absolutely believe in the market
if tiktok were somehow to drop
away tomorrow. And whether it's
an American company, French
company and Indian company there
will be a replacement site where
people can still be creative and
earn that kind of living. I
believe the market will provide
that number one number two on
the question of no evidence
respectfully. We see press
report after press reports. And
you know, tiktok says, oh, I'm
sorry Chinese engineers got it.
This time Chinese engineers got
another time you've got frankly
individuals who are
whistleblowers coming out, and I
think this threat is real. And
one of the things that my
legislation would do is required
the intelligence community to
declassify as much information
as possible, so it's not don't
just trust the government and
final point I make is this this
is not just an issue in the
United States. Look at the other
nations, Canada's bandit off of
their government phones. Britain
has the same recently, the
Netherlands said. If you're a
journalist don't have this on
your phone because the Chinese
are monitoring your journalistic
activities. India has already
banned it outright. We want to
ask you about banking as well,
Caitlin. Well, I obviously we
saw what happened yesterday. I
know you wanted to see a pause
in the interest rate hikes from
the federal reserve. Obviously
that did not happen yesterday.
We saw what we heard from people
. But I had a separate question
from you, which is on donations
you received from svb which you
said you would return. I believe
that there's malfeasance to be
found. Why not just return them
now, though, senator because,
listen, if there's malfeasance,
and I believe you, it sure as
heck appears to me that the bank
was a little bit asleep at the
switch and the basic prudential
regulation didn't kick in. This
was interest and banking one oh,
one there was an interest rate
mismatch. Um I will absolutely
return. Once we've seen the
results of how this came about.
If there's malfeasance, this
money goes back. That'll be.
We'll figure that out by may
1st. That's when the vice chair
of the fed will make its report
the other thing that I think we
have to look at this and I don't
have a good answer on this is we
have never seen a run driven by
the internet this quickly. $42
billion came out of this bank in
one day in six hours. That's the
equivalent of 25 cents on every
dollar. And candidly. There were
some folks from the venture
capital community who I believe
inside this run. I'm not sure
that's illegal, but it sure
seems pretty darn immoral. But
we got to get the answers first.
And if there needs to be, for
example, corrections reforms
that I supported back in 2018
count me in. I think at the end
of the day this is going to be
the basic failure of prudential
regulation one. Oh, one. Can I
just ask a follow up to that
because, according to public
filings over the last 10 years,
your campaign and your team has
received over $21,000 from svb,
including 5600 from the former
CEO Gary Becker. I think
everyone agrees there was
certainly mismanagement at the
least at that firm in terms of
interest rate, uh, protections
you've called for and just past
week for executives and their
bonuses from svb to be clawed
back. Why should there's be
clawed back and your campaign
donations not be returned. First
and foremost. Campaign
contributions have never
affected any bullet policy
decision I've ever made full
stop and I will make the
determination once the report is
done, and I expect I'll probably
be giving this back to charity
the way a couple of other
members have. But I do think we
ought to get our facts first.
Um, and when we see the report,
and matter of fact, I'm going to
get a chance to talk to Mr bar
next week in a public hearing if
he's got an interim report, and
there is the evidence that
malfeasance clearly this bank,
it appears at least didn't have
a risk officer eight of the last
12 months that's another glaring
red flag. I am. I think others
will take that action. But let's
get the facts first. The irony
is some folks are proposing a
solution set before we actually
have the facts. Let's get the
facts, correct it. Make sure it
doesn't happen again. And I sure
as heck believe there ought to
be clawbacks. If there is the
malfeasance that you've
suggested, alright, we
understand and a full
investigation and getting the
reports okay, that that's
certainly smart. Can we just I
just want to get back to bottom
line this tiktok and bite dance.
Because there are lots of apps
out there. Get our information,
you know, Twitter, tiktok,
Facebook and so on meta the big
difference for you because
people at home are watching. Why
is this any different? Wise
tiktok any difference is the big
difference. The Chinese
communist government having
access to our information. Is
that the bottom line here? The
bottom line is that the Chinese
communist party being able to
access that data. And
potentially using it for
nefarious purposes. Spying on
folks that may be part of the
Chinese diaspora. Frankly
they're against the government
and also this being used as a
propaganda tool in the American
sites. Listen, I think there
ought to be privacy rules. I
think there ought to be dated
portability. I think we need
reforms on the section 2 30,
which frankly gives these
American sites and get out of
jail free card. No matter what
they put forward, and I think
congress ought to act on that.
But as chairman of the
intelligence committee I believe
tiktok poses a national security
threat before all the potential